a new r-tx card the 2060 so I'm here in
Montreal and right before CES look what
shows up rap it's another r-tx lunch
we're gonna have the all-
put a click bake title this sucks but
there's a really that bad you know what
Demetri it might be pretty damn good
which is it let's find out right after
this what would you like
so I'm looking for a gaming headset with
a bit of everything but not overkill
something that folds on your neck sure
how about the light frame without
excessive clamping force yes yes you
have to will ear cushions with proper
internal padding excellent I will take
the cable and the microphone are
removable
fine fine this is the one multi-platform
compatibility with virtual surround
sound dongle avail can I just take one
and the sound quality you'll be
satisfied with so the new coolermaster
MH 751 and 75 to are here to make your
gaming experience
alright good people so let's talk about
the specs because Nvidia actually did
not cut all that much when compared to
the RT X 2070 the RT X 2060 uses the
exact same tu 106 core but it cuts out
six streaming multi processors to 32-bit
memory controllers some Rob's and l2
cache that means the RT X 2060 ends up
with the exact same specs as the last
generation gtx 1070 but uses a narrower
192 bit memory interface and 6 gigabytes
of fast GDD r 6 memory and even runs at
the exact same two speeds too but when
compared to gains the gtx 1060 that it's
supposed to replace the RT x 2060 is
superior and basically every way it has
50% more cores and texture units while
also offering a ton more memory
bandwidth that sexy gigabytes may be the
only limiter in some games but with
Turing's updated memory architecture it
may not be too much of an issue and the
real question is about the price and
honestly guys the entire RT x series is
pretty expensive but obviously the RT x
2060 will be compared directly against
the gtx 960 so that card launched at
$300 for the founders edition and pre
overclocked card
but eventually settled to around 250
bucks
the gtx970 s these days go for around
350 and the gtx 1070 TI for around 450
but what about the gtx 1080 well good
luck finding those at the reasonable
prices and so the r TX 2060 is launching
at $350 for the founders edition and
board partner cards so there is no fe
tax and will be high priced for pre
overclocked models and so it's basically
$100 more than the GTX 1060 is right now
and you know that $100 price hike is
quite a lot to ask for a 6 Series cards
so from a pricing perspective it aligns
a bit more which is gtx 1070 and then
the gtx 1060 and also remember the RT x
27 t cards start at $4.99 so could this
be the RT x card we've all been waiting
for let's see unlike other efi cards
this one is not overclocked and does not
have a premium price it looks amazing
it's probably one of the best-looking RT
x 2060 cards around it measures only
nine and quarter of inch so about 23
centimeters which is pretty compact
there is a 6 pin connector on the back
location is not too much of a problem
for most cases even ITX but be aware
that it will add about one inch to the
overall length of the card and video
says the location of the 6 pin was
chosen to be placed in the back so that
the top looks much cleaner when
installed inside the case and I would
agree there's black area next to the
power connector looks like it's some
sort of accessory but it's actually for
support brackets that system integrators
sometimes used to secure the GPU in
place and like the 27 t it does not
support SLI now for this review you
wanted to do things differently so
you'll still see individual benchmarks
later in the video but right now let's
look at the overall performance of the
RT X 2016 so based on an average of all
the benchmarks the RT X 2060 is about
the same performance as the gtx 1070 TI
and also nearly beating out the vega 56
that means it's also between 40 and 50
percent faster than the gtx 1066 gear
bite version depending on the game and
one interesting thing is that it cost
$150 less than the RT x 2070 but is only
about
15% slower on average and honestly guys
this makes the r-tx 2070 look like a
pretty poor value for 1080p and 1440p
and speaking of value check the sound
guys with the r-tx 2060 sitting at $350
it leads everything else based on the
amount of money you pay for performance
at 1080p and sure if you find that gtx
970 or 1070 TI on the crazy sale you
might be better off with those but the
2060s price to performance ratio is
still pretty far ahead
the nice thing about the 2060 is that
it's performance does not fall apart at
high resolutions and it actually pulls a
bit further away from all other cards at
1440p and this could make it a really
good option for someone who has plans to
upgrade their 1080p monitors in the
future to 1440p 1440p for life and while
the r-tx 2060 may be ahead in these
charts it is expensive when compared to
the GTX 1060 really expensive since
paying $100 more is a huge amount in
this category and the 350 dollar price
point really means it takes over from
the gtx 1070 and the older 970 rather
than the gtx 1060 and honestly if you
already have a gtx 1070 there's
absolutely no reason for you to upgrade
alright so let's get into the benchmarks
as we go through these charts I want to
talk a bit about price creep because
it's a real problem that's been
highlighted here the second someone here
is about a sixty series NVIDIA GPU they
might right away think it's you know an
affordable graphics card that combines
performance with great value and yes the
2060 does provide good value for its
price in our charts but that does not
mean that it is affordable at $350 this
is an expensive GPU that will not fit
into many people's budgets remember the
gtx 960 was launched at $200 the gtx
1060 had the shelfs starting at 250 and
now the r-tx 2060 is $100 more putting
it into the same you know price
territory as the original $380 lunch
price of custom GTX 10 70s and that
really hurts for anyone expecting a
cheap RTX 2060 like I said if you're
sporting a GTX 1060 or a 960 this really
is not the card for
since it costs a lot more than what you
originally paid the worst part about the
situation is that GT x-series cards are
not only running out of stock but are
also starting to get price hikes due to
supply versus demand so unless a m-- he
comes up with something really
interesting anyone looking to upgrade or
build a new gaming system will be forced
into this higher price structure there's
nothing consumer-friendly about this
guys especially when those are TX
features can only be used in a few games
luckily given its performance the r-tx
2060 does not consume a lot of power
like the AMD cards but its overall
performance per watt is not much better
than that of the GTX 970 and the 1070 TI
but it's also pretty quiet I do have to
mention that the lack of any RT X games
aside from bf5 and some benchmarks you
know that's a big problem for Nvidia
especially because you know it's been
almost four months since the first RT X
card was launched and all the other
games that were promised with RT X
features enabled are taking forever to
be delivered to hours as gamers and so
if you pick up the RT X 2060 you know
it's pretty expensive and without those
additional features your money is just
going towards a promise and nothing else
so there you have it guys the RT X 2060
what do you think about its performance
and its overall kind of placement within
the market
I am hoping for more competition in 2019
to hopefully bring those prices down all
right guys I'm Dmitri thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video and this is Mike signing off from
Montreal that's been the RT x 2060 video
and we will see you
yes